news voice is the world's first mobile
app that helps you track
where your news is coming from news
voice helps you track what corporate
interests might be influencing the
narratives in the news you read every
day
arm yourself against corporate media
monopolies by downloading the news voice
app
for free using the link right underneath
this video
uh joe biden's wife jill biden
potentially the future first lady of the
united states depending on what happens
in november
is pretty clever and she's also quite
astute when it comes to dealing with
media now certainly she's had media
training i'm guessing it has been ramped
up
given that joe biden is the nominee but
she seems to have a bit of a natural
ability for this i'm going to play a
clip for you today of jill biden
completely shutting down
cnn's jake tapper who tries to bring up
the issue of joe biden's gaffe
and jill biden does something that is
really it's a clinic on how to be
interviewed she says gaffs trump is
president what are you talking about joe
biden's gaffe so i'm gonna play the clip
for you
then we'll discuss it i'm resisting my
instinct
to first tell you all of the interesting
things about this clip
i'm not going to do that let's watch it
first and then we will talk about it
your husband has been known
to make the occasional gaffe oh you
can't even go there you can
after donald trump you cannot even say
the word
i can't even say the word no but are you
not
done it's gone the gaff issue is over
because
so over so jake tapper doesn't even know
how to respond and what jill biden did
here is super interesting
both from the perspective of the
interviewer and the perspective of the
interviewee now i've been on both sides
of this i've been the interviewer
asking questions of a guest that the
guest may not want to answer
i've also been a guest being asked
questions
that i either you know it's not
typically that i don't want to answer
them but that i either find boring or
lame or distracting or
improperly framed questions so i've been
on both sides of this
joe biden has handled this perfectly in
that she resisted opening up the can of
worms
she reframed as we talk about it in a
moment you'll see what i mean
and she did it in a charming and
friendly way
without attacking the interviewer and
without making it awkward
but simultaneously reminding the
audience of how absurd it is to talk
about joe biden's gaffes
when the president is donald trump there
are two other ways that she could have
done this
based on the typical media training and
preparation so
one thing that jill biden could have
done and she didn't do it one thing she
could have done is
to do a typical standard reframe and
pivot okay
so that would be something like
acknowledging biden's gaffes
but pivoting to issues which would start
with some kind of mild acknowledgement
it might be
you know what about what about the
gaffes you know my husband he says
what's on his mind he's passionate and
sometimes things come out in a way
that he would redo if given the chance
but what this election is really about
is the future of this country and
healthcare and coronavirus
so i'm sure if you've watched any
interviews in your life you've heard
people respond that way when interviewed
and the downside of it is it does feel
like not answering the question because
it's not really answering the question
so she didn't do that the other way jill
biden could have responded
would have been to sort of more
forcefully and noticeably refuse to
answer and that often looks very
bad right so i'm not here to talk about
that or
this is an election about issues not
about gaffes or
no comment right i mean that's really
really bad that's not good
and she didn't do that but what jill
biden does and we're going to watch it a
second time now armed with the knowledge
of how to interpret this
what jill biden does is to essentially
make it a big joke
while being friendly and reminding
people that biden's gaffes
are nothing compared to trump's years of
insults and attacks
attacks and mocking a disabled reporter
using racist and xenophobic terms
suggesting people inject bleach and on
and on and on and the way you know that
this was effective
is that jake tapper he's just out of
ideas he retreats
to just repeating what she says jake
tapper says oh the issue is over
let's look at it one more time your
husband has been known
um to make the occasional gaffe
uh oh you can't even go there you can
after donald trump you cannot
even say the
it's gone the gaf issue is over because
over
so over so this might not seem that
notable if you don't look at it more
deeply
but that is actually a very skilled and
tactful way to handle this question and
this issue
and by the way it's not just optics jill
biden is right
sure joe biden has been gaff-prone over
the years
donald trump gaffs every week of this
presidency
as much as joe biden has in the last
decade and she was able to make that
point
without insulting jake tapper without
attacking the question
or the network it's also quite frankly a
bit of a lazy question
let's now look at it from the
interviewer's point of view
if jake tapper wants to prevent jill
biden
from being able to do this he has to
come up
with something more specific your
husband once said
x and that was deeply offensive to why
why do you think he hasn't apologized is
he unwilling to admit that that was a
mistake
you have to frame the question more
powerfully because if jake tapper does
that
jill biden can't get out of it as easily
and as smoothly as she did so
this is partially that jill biden
handled the question really well and
wasn't going to put up with this
absurd idea that the biden gaffes are
the problem when
you look at the last four years of trump
but also jake tapper brought it up in
sort of a lazy way and it allowed her to
do this but
her identifying it quickly and diffusing
it
in a friendly and cordial way was what
was astute really a clinic on how to
handle interviews
let me know what you think let me know
what you're expecting for tonight's
debate which we will be
live for starting at 8 30 p.m eastern
time on youtube twitch and facebook
i'm on twitter at dpakman i look forward
to hearing from you